dear fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Carol Jonah ifahir today
we are going to use nvidia's new AI to
create absolutely magical time-lapse
videos that were otherwise nearly
impossible to make until now you see
watching a video of a landscape in real
time is a smooth experience but not as
interesting as seemingly nothing is
happening now speeding them up creates
us a Time Lapse video this is finally
interesting however then this happens oh
yes we get too much flickering this is
not for human consumption that's for
sure if only an AI based algorithm
existed that could somehow take the
essence of the changes in this video but
make it smooth as well now of course
that sounds flat out impossible why well
in these time lapse videos we experience
drastic weather changes within a day
photos for some days are missing and
even worse occlusions might happen now
let's have a look at the previous method
trying to do that
hmm something is happening here it is
able to keep the weather conditions
stable so we get no more flickering
however do you see the problem growing
is clearly happening but the details
have been washed out so much that the
most interesting part of the video is
now gone I am not that hopeful that this
is possible to solve well but just in
case let's have a look at nvidia's new
Ai and see what it is made of this is
the input and wow the new method does an
absolutely outstanding job at keeping
the weather conditions stable but in the
meantime also showing us sharp footage
of this amazing growth now let's compare
it to the previous method and my
goodness there is no contest here so
much better loving it and let's have a
look at another example of this Valley
and then I will show you that this
technique also has some more superpowers
as expected the input video has way too
much going on so now let's ask the new
method to boil it down to its essence
that is absolutely incredible look
smooth and detailed at the same time and
yes I promised some superpowers so what
are those well this technique can not
only stabilize the weather conditions
and create smooth and detailed videos
but one depending on our artistic goals
it even gives us tools to control the
time of day
and if we wish to think bigger we can
also control the time of year
but all that is nothing compared to my
favorite so hold on to your papers for
Trends what is that if there are
structural changes in a landscape or a
city for instance at some point this
building has been repainted and now we
can decide to forget about it and keep
it as if it never even happened or we
can even decide to use its new
appearance for the entirety of the Year
even before it was painted wow and we
can also account for growth this growth
can take place as the video progresses
or look it can be fixed in time this is
so good I love it and now time for some
interesting tidbits and this technique
is based on the legendary stargen system
which is able to synthesize these
photorealistic humans and and other
things in a somewhat controllable manner
also I bet the authors had a few
conversations asking each other how on
Earth do we put all this video
information into one stationary image in
the paper this concept is a little
harder to convey there so I am so happy
to be able to show you these videos
instead and what I also loved is this
look are you seeing what I am seeing my
goodness some of these data sets have
not only a few days missing here and
there there are often a series of tens
of days missing or even worse and the no
AI can still create a smooth video of
the changes as if nothing happened it
synthesizes what happened in between and
there is something that is even worse
look the reality of taking these photos
is that the location of the camera can
change over the year making this Barn
appear to be bending upwards and the new
AI can fix that too not a problem at all
it is absolutely incredible that humans
are able to build ai-based algorithms
that are disscapable today what a time
to be alive now not even this technique
is perfect you see here that for
instance the chairs are still moving
around but have a look at how much
progress has been made just one more
paper down the line my mind is
officially blown and good news the
source code and pre-trained models are
also available so everyone who has the
available resources and expertise can
start using it right now and given
nvidia's excellent track record in Tech
transfer this might make an introduction
in one of their product soon so what do
you think what would you use this for
let me know in the comments below if
you're looking for inexpensive Cloud
gpus for AI Lambda now offers the best
prices in the world for GPU Cloud
compute no commitments or negotiation
required just sign up and launch an
instance and hold on to your papers
because with Lambda GPU Cloud you can
get on-demand a100 instances for 1.10
per hour versus 4.10 per hour with AWS
that's 73 savings did I mention they
also offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and Caltech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lambdalabs.com papers to
sign up for one of their amazing GPU
instances today thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time